now to our coverage of the coronavirus  cases and deaths keep  rising and now one local hospital is  issuing a disaster declaration  the intensive care unit at saint rose  dominican's san martin campus  is now at 137 percent capacity  staff are stopping most surgeries there  and they're opening some areas of the  building  just for coronavirus care last week you  may remember our eye team reported at  least  five valley hospitals had icu's that  exceeded a hundred percent  nevada is still seeing above average  case numbers here's the latest  today the state reported more than 1100  new cases and 50 more deaths  and most are as you would imagine from  here in clark county however covet 19  hospitalizations across nevada have  actually been decreasing  from the peaks in late december